i mean if somebody says for instance
well what what have you produced in the
west other than uh other than
slavery and racism and inequality and
all of these things i say okay let me
just start with cities paris
rome
florence barcelona madrid
lisbon
venice portland used to be nice i
wouldn't list portland
the point is
the city the list could go on almost
endlessly the great university cities
heidel heidelberg
regensburg oxford cambridge
you think this is nothing
i'm just talking about cities here i've
not even got onto the rest of it i've
not got on to scientific achievements
i've not got on to all the cultural
achievements
but i could
so this is sort of the same question
that i asked you
at the beginning in terms of why didn't
our institutions have enough to stand up
our secular institutions but are you
surprised that the religious
institutions whether you fully believe
in them or not that they didn't have
better defenses you would think that
these things that have really lasted for
thousands of years and have made
mistakes along the way and wars have
been fought and we can do that whole
thing
but that day that every you're not
exaggerating when you talk about what's
happening in the churches and the
temples of america right now i mean
they've traded in most of what we
thought their beliefs were and it's very
it's very strange because i mean i agree
with the
historian of christianity sort of
ancient world um tom holland who who
said in the past you know that actually
christianity for instance it should do
the weird stuff like
what makes christianity extraordinary
are
the claims it makes about the world
um
if
the weird stuff as tom holland calls it
you know include you know the virgin
birth
the crucifixion the resurrection
but this is this is christianity
take them away and you haven't got
christianity
insert in its place
the same as i say but now
things that you get everywhere else in
the age and you don't really have a
religion you just
got another iteration of the social
justice movement but i believe i believe
that weird stuff is absolutely central
to it
um
same thing with judaism uh
it's the things that make them different
from everything else that are the things
that you'd want to hold on to not the
stuff you'd give up yeah and and import
this like crappy deangeloism
why would you
why would you go from angels to d'angelo
that's a good question i should have uh
i consider dennis prager my rabbi i'll
have him i'll have him ask that next
time at the high holidays uh well from
there actually that's a good segue to
gratitude which is next in the book
man we could all use a little bit more
of that in the west huh yeah i think
some people are kind of waking up to it
now do you sense that there is a feeling
of oh man we might be really giving this
thing away
maybe things like ukraine remind us of
that you know you've got
people in 2022's homes are being shelled
by tanks from an invading neighboring
country and
you know it could be us you know
maybe it helps a little bit to put in
proportion
the luck we have in
basically stable and vaguely peaceful
societies or broadly peaceful
substantially peaceful mainly peaceful
societies
um
you know the reason why i write about
gratitude is because apartheid in fact
it's been something that's been much my
mind in recent years it's as i say it's
the only counter you can have to
resentment and we we've lived in an age
of resentment and the war on the west is
significantly a war waged by resentful
people
people who
wallow in resentment who wallow in
blaming other people for anything in
their lives that does not go right
you always have someone to blame
nietzsche again writes about this
the problem with resentment the problem
with resentful people
is that there is actually only one true
answer you can have to them to stop
their resentment which is to say to them
you are right
there is something
which is wrecking your life and is
ruining you
the thing is you
you are the thing
now
the problem with that is that that is
the last message anyone wants to hear
and so there will always be
an inbuilt reason for resentful people
to stop ever looking inwards
is that the greatest trick of social
justice in a way that it took everything
off the self it took everything off the
individual and just put it on the
machine it's certainly one of them
and you know you have to talk to these
things in similar but similar depths and
by the way i think this is something
right has got very badly wrong in recent
years
uh the left talks in terms of resentment
and the right will talk about tax cuts
you know that's not actually talking on
the same level yeah they're talking at a
tectonic level and the right is talking
at a fiddling level important fiddling
no doubt but fiddling
um the only counter to real resentment
is gratitude is is to turn your attitude
towards life around
and to be encouraged to do so now
this is perfectly possible but
and one of the things is to realize what
a life of resentment actually looks like
dostoyevsky and the brothers karamazov
um
has a a fantastic passage where the
devil appears and
says to one of the brothers the one the
brother he says on the brothers that
gratitude is something he can't do
and when i read that first i thought
that's amazing only dostoevsky would
throw away that insight that the devil
is not capable of gratitude but you know
the gratitude comes or should come from
okay these are things that uh i mean if
somebody says for instance well what
what have you produced in the west other
than uh other than
slavery and racism and inequality and
all of these things i say okay let me
just start with cities paris
rome
florence
barcelona madrid
lisbon
venice portland used to be nice i
wouldn't list portland
the point is the city the list could go
on almost endlessly
the great university cities heidel
heidelberg
regensburg oxford cambridge
you think this is nothing
i'm just talking about cities here i've
not even got onto the rest of it i've
not got on to scientific achievements
i've not got on to all the cultural
achievements
but i could
now if you look at it in that light
you'll be reminded that
yes it's possible to do what the
deconstructionists
argue that we should all do which is to
tear everything apart break everything
down always deconstruct everything other
than their own careers
um
you can do that or you can stand back
and look at what you have i mean you
could you could you could look at a
block of marble and talk about the labor
that it cost to get it out of the
of the of the
the ground you could talk about the cost
of labor and whether or not people were
properly uh
paid for getting it out of the ground or
you could stand back and look at
the pieta
you know
these are two totally different
attitudes but they're both possible
you can stand in in venice and say what
a terrible testimony to inequality
or you could marvel
yeah
you know and there's one that's better
than the other i think that's what
you're saying get what i'm leading i
think i think i got it i think i got it
uh culture is what you end on and we've
sort of this whole conversation in some
ways is couched around culture but
everyone says we're in a culture war
right now or the culture wars are raging
uh yes the the cultural one is the most
painful one in a way because this is
where
the
d'angelos and kendeism
this is where it is it is really at its
ugliest
is when this horrible retributive game
looking at everything through the eyes
of slavery and colonialism
gets put onto this horrible beam gets
put onto the most delicate fragile and
precious things
i give examples of artwork that
has actually been
closed up now
including one of my favorite painters
uh
his work's been shut away in the tate
gallery in london because of a claim
that one of the one of the figures in it
is racist
and the man who painted this rex
whistler um
died on his first day in action in 1944
in normandy
uh he's posthumously been defamed
by the tate gallery as a racist he
wasn't a racist
uh and he lost his life fighting nazism
and they've defamed him posthumously
they've done the same thing with artist
after artist they're doing the same
thing with classical music at the moment
they can't find enough
black baroque composers
so what yeah so what
uh and but there are baroque ensembles
across america that are now tearing
themselves apart over this orchestra's
doing the same thing
they notice that i mean that the canon
of western music and western literature
is horribly dominated by
by what they call dead white males
by the way one of the things i love in
that is that they they don't only attack
people for being white and being males
but for being dead
it's like what kind of a loser would die
the least they could do is stick around
so we can attack them to their faces you
know what kind of losers are these
people like
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell